this [ __ ] story is my 22 year old
female boyfriend what website is this
off of our e d di t it's a scaffolding
website so scaffold us
okay keep gon do long list a lot a lot
of it is long do we lost scaffold do you
know what do you see what I'm saying you
you nailed your pretty that's perfect
I've come to chop the shoreline luck I'm
not sure look the way I feel uh are you
feeling it alright so my 22 year old
female boyfriend 22 year old males farts
are ruining our relationship I thought
this would be here tomorrow this is the
exclusive [ __ ] you can't get this
anywhere else yeah no this is this is a
[ __ ] holographic Charizard of reddit
post man I really hope that this chick
didn't post this and then her boyfriend
saw it
so she deleted it and finally they've
diffused this issue and now we're just
going to reignite the flame we're gonna
wind them up yeah alright so I read that
boyfriend of four months has
uncontrollably rancid files I've been on
a road trip with him and two other
people 19 and 21 for three weeks now and
I'm at my breaking point today in
particular was nauseating was it'd be
nauseating nology Nagi we've been on a
nine-hour Drive and every time he farts
it proceeds to laugh maniacally and
locks the windows [ __ ] dope dope er
this is what you get for dating a frat
dude yes you should know that's funny
like once ya know repeatedly that's not
I can hear the Joker laughs now this is
the origin story of the Joker
some people just want to watch the world
stink the first race the temperature in
the car no he's just turning on the
heater to be an [ __ ] that's the part
you're missing no it's funny to think of
his farts actually being that hot yeah
just like a hot [ __ ] infrared just
fun
you know red gas consuming the car the
farts raise the temperature in the car
considerably make my eyes water
damn so they're spicy nice taste it we
got [ __ ] curry powder in that [ __ ]
yeah and on multiple occasions have made
me gag and nearly vomit oh my god damn
bros guys cuts he's got a weapon
yeah this guy's got some power his
stomach is a weapon bro registered yeah
she got a serial number on it's potent
he has a [ __ ] limit on how much [ __ ]
he can eat does it past a certain point
it's like a he's federal permit to be
eating that much curry because what
comes out of his ass yeah
his intestines license I keep telling
him to change his diet or go to
gastrointestinal intestinal specialist
because I cannot take it anymore oh my
god man let's let my significant other
tell me you need to see a
gastrointestinal specialist in an
argument see how I react I would be if
someone legit told me that I'd be like I
do have a problem I would you have bad
farts for months at a time that's not
natural this has been happening for
months look I understand once in a while
let anyone let anyone rip but this is
constant in the car in front of my
parents during sex that's a no-no and
every time he just laughs many times he
farts into his hand and well he can
throw it if you can if you can ball up
your fart is this full an avatar is this
full hang like the [ __ ] spot like the
style bender like he can fart into his
hand
and throw it at you like a snowball yeah
in melting of all the rest of the notes
you ever seen that video we might have
even watched this before on the podcast
but that video from my like Japanese
game show of them like to looking at a
dude farting on infrared camera and he's
trying to escape his own farts
oh yeah testing like what's the best way
to escape your fart is I uh I've
definitely seen that clip I don't think
we watched on the podcast we should
bring that up afterward that's so funny
oh and everytime he just laughs many
times he farts into his hands was it now
I'm trying not to be unreasonable I love
him a lot he's a perfect minute for me I
don't care that he farts a lot
I cannot handle the smell and this is
where my screenshot cut off damn and I
want to know the comments this is what I
think some actual advice oh yeah no we
do have the comments I'm starting to
find him disgusting okay so there you
know some people are stating that you
could argue this as a form of abuse I
mean I guess people saying you're worth
more aim higher he's a little kid I mean
let's not let's not okay let's let's
these are like full-on essays man people
right and dude people got MLA formatted
let's not get confused farts are [ __ ]
hysterical
yeah they absolutely are probably one of
the funniest things on planet earth are
farts but in just like anything that's
funny
you can't overdo it yeah you can yeah
yeah you got it you can't kill the bit
you can't kill the bit and this guy
sounds like he's overdoing it a little
bit yeah I wouldn't go as far as to say
this is this is abuse it just seems like
it's kind of like a Chuck you leave food
out all the time and yeah you know
that's that it's just like an annoyance
like this dude is it is it is it child
and yeah the the smell is [ __ ]
annoying mmhmm mm-hmm
but yeah it's not a guy just to stop
doing that okay
dr. Phil a [ __ ] right there
why don't you tell your boyfriend to
stop just stop farting don't fart
anymore [ __ ] here's what I say you do
I say you're like babe I want to try
something different
he's like alright you say you so into
farting I want you to fart on my face
yeah mm-hmm
no no no okay go ahead and then you know
he's like all right all right yeah all
right yeah you want me for him yeah your
turn around want you to front of my face
and then when he turns around you get
one of those Nair uh you get an air
strip uh-huh covered in wax and you just
smack it right on his [ __ ] okay right
along the hair of his ass okay you save
his ass no no you just leave it on mmm
so you want to fart again go ahead turn
that thing off then you go fart again
and it's just like a it's like a
reminder so like he's gonna have to go
through some pain to get back to where
he was and you'll make him appreciate
what he had before yeah and not to use
it willy-nilly yep and you know take his
[ __ ] away from him yeah I see disarm
or how's this okay
get him get him a butt plug for every
single gift so like talk Valentine's Day
versus a crazy as [ __ ] keep getting him
butt plugs different colors though like
mix it up pink purple I mean you could
get ones with little figurines you know
what cool little things attached to them
you know there's a ton of bugs you can
get but just keep so when he'll fart in
front of your parents get him a butt
plug in front of his parents yeah for
his birthday
yeah oh yeah your son oh then he's this
it's cuz he farts all the following
behind I'm or fight fire with fire
bus back when you're having sex with him
get off turn around farting his dick he
might just look at that and go alright
okay yeah so maybe he's in tonight
yeah it sounds like maybe yes obviously
love your idle fetish she looks back at
him and she's like I never I've never
been I never thought you would
my little pharfignewton hit that again
you know fart very hey come on party
games like poking our stomach won't do
it do it do it do it again that's the
problem man you might not be able to
fart back because our man's might be
into it are you my stinky little
princess yeah you are a little stinky
that's the world a stinker it's not a
word creative world do they just fart
together yeah they live in this [ __ ]
green house of their own
fucking's of their own scent so won't
work yeah everyone is like oh good thing
I made breakfast for this one again no I
think I think I think this isn't [ __ ]
this is farting its dad
this is gas it's gas is gas that's the
title that's the title of this episode
this shit's gas it's gas
you